it's hard to believe isn't it the tokyo
olympics are finally over it has been
a successful 17 days for team gb
65 medals in total to match the tally
won
at london 2012. only the usa china
and japan won more but as always the
tokyo games
will be remembered for far more than
simply
the medal winners joining us now to look
back at the games and some of the most
memorable moments you can see there
olympic silver and bronze medalist chris
akabusi great to see
you today i suppose you can have a lion
now have you been up
all night and in the early hours for the
past two weeks oh nick i've been i've
been absolutely
glued to it i've loved every minute of
it
and particularly it came to life for me
as an athlete you know watching the two
weeks of the olympia
athletic olympiad and some great
performances
the um let's talk about jason kenny i'm
gathering we should
do i left it to the last day many didn't
think he'd
do it but there he is getting gold and
the most decorated olympian
ever yeah i'm obviously a true olympic
performer he's got great pedigree
he's seen um sir chris hoy do his thing
he's obviously was inspired by people
like um oh gosh go but the
the role was redgrave and pin set and
he's realized
i can do this you know i could be top of
that tree so it's a brilliant accolade
for him
and great for united kingdom and talking
about uh laura as well wasn't quite to
be
today for her but hugely successful in
her own right hasn't she been and
indeed being the the flag bearer for
team gb at the closing ceremony
yeah let's say it was as a great duo
there you know that
they i remember actually when they um
got together
from the um 2012 games you know
and the surprise of the law when she
actually won
in 2012 you know that fantastic olympiad
for us
and then she's gone on with her husband
now to
set so many records between them
it's a great feat and great for them as
a household
and great for us as a nation yeah and
what else has uh
caught your eye on the track and field
high jump
final perhaps or no no no no no no no no
nick for me
uh the performance of the games
carsten valham in the formula hurdles
totally obliterated the world record and
basically
what we saw there was a roger bannister
moment
you know from for what what he has done
is rewritten the rules
or finding me as a hurdling it makes
people like myself
realize that when we were doing it with
all due respect
we were jogging you know we were we were
of our time
and we're competing under what we
thought was peak performance
but we're two seconds behind this guy
and it's just
absolutely phenomenal what he's done
you know and still hold a british record
but not for long now that people have
seen what he's done
i i predict there's gonna be a whole
host of performances now
of people running 46 and a half trying
to get into that 45 seconds
a phenomenal feat that if you're not
really linked to the front of hurdles
you quite can't
quite understand if i say edwin moses
who ran 122 consecutive finals
undefeated for 10 years double olympic
champion
would have been 10 to 12 meters
behind carsten varhom you can understand
the fate
of that man well that's a huge accolade
a huge tribute you're paying there
obviously with with your successes so
and we've had successes in sports that
we haven't had before what about the
boxing yesterday
uh gala the young brommy
yeah was absolutely brilliant and i
loved
you know seeing him and his brother
interacting
quite clearly a guy on a mission and yet
when it happened
couldn't was it couldn't actually
believe it became so understated it was
like
i've waited all my life for this i
worked so hard for this
and now and that happens doesn't it
sometimes you it's been such a dream
it's such a dream that when it comes to
reality you become stunned
very very humble in in victory there it
wasn't he
a huge success for a number of sports as
i say that that haven't been recognized
before and we've done better i suppose
this
this olympics we've done better in some
than we expected and perhaps worse than
others i'm thinking the rowing perhaps
this time not not as good
yeah look but nikki you can't you can't
always be top of the tree
sometimes at this level you're going to
accept that your competitors
are going to get that one step ahead of
you what i actually loved about this
olympics actually
was things like the skateboarding
and the bmx in things that you don't
readily
link with the olympics and we saw real
youth
virtuosity we saw gymkhana
and of course you know you saw the
essence of the games
young people answering the calming call
and of course when i talk about young
people
i've got mentioned tom daley a little
darling
you saw him with his knitting but
finally
getting that gold medal step by step
inch by inch it's plugged away and
tom is now olympic gold
medalist what is it what does it mean
for somebody
getting gold after so long
of trying so so many years so many
olympics well
i think you know whether it's gold or
whether it's like holly butch when you
get a bones medal
or law a meal when she gets a silver
what it actually does it says
all the work that you've done all the
people
that supported you the coach the
managers the asians the friends the
family
the training partner the physios
all of those people they didn't do it in
vain
but they spotted that talent they
invested in that talent
and their permission came down at the
end of the line now these guys might go
on and do some phenomenal stuff
but when you've done two three olympiads
and you've been that close
it's great to get that far and of course
we've got paris
just three years away given the fact
that these olympics
were delayed by 12 months yeah and you
know
what we saw for some people that the
delay of last year
came too late for them and yet the delay
of the last last year
gave opportunities for others again in
the athletics
you've got kelly keeley hutchison and
gemma riku
really matured in in a period when last
year they might not have been ready
now they've got another three years and
what i'm hoping for
in track and field for example we had
some tragedy
i hope that's not too strong a word kjt
kabutina johnson thompson dean asher
smith
both turned up injured and they didn't
make it this time well
i'm hoping that those three years is
close enough
for them to really get their teeth into
it and for those guys
to take on the mantle of jessica ennis
hill
greg rutherford mo fowler in athletics
we're missing
our top top leading lights and hopefully
those guys can go on and do it
in 2024 in paris yeah we'll never forget
uh super saturday from 2012 will we
chris acaba
you could go on for ages but sadly time
has beaten us thanks as ever
for coming on to the program today take
care god